كانت رسوم una في Zara yakumo التجريبية
للطاقة في المنطقة مدارس Phil Alam للتزلج في دبي
Tatas كانت امرأة كبيرة تتمتع
بالقرار de Chile Oaxaca - L تم
إخبار Gia Icarus أنها أزياء Hutton's
illa rahmatan المجانية مع Mia - Tori
walaikum Alma هل يمكنك قبول -  يمكننا
تصوير أبنر بوركا لرؤية بهاتي لكن مع الاحتفاظ
ببئر ، أنت الكينوا التي وقفت بجانب
لوكا وربطتها بها باردة جدًا ولكن
معظم الناس يقولون إنها تستحق العناء لأنها
تجربة فريدة حقًا في واحدة
من الأولى من نوعها في هذا  من
المستحيل أن يكون العالم مردوخ باريس مصابًا بالحساسية تجاه
النهاية ، نيا الله ، لقد حصلت على لقطة
في المنطقة حيث كان محمد عطا يملأ
ما يعنيه علاج كابيلا لك
وهو يرتد دولارًا على المكوك
عندما أكون العمدة ناهاني
أتخلى عني.  قل دائمًا أن
طيور البطريق لدينا هي أكثر طيور البطريق ودية
في العالم لأنك تعلم أننا قضينا
الكثير من الوقت معهم ، فالمدرب
لديه علاقات وثيقة جدًا معهم ،
فهم لطيفون للغاية ومحبوبون جدًا
لك  تعرف بمجرد دخولك
إلى موطنهم ، ركضوا
ليأتوا ويرحبوا بك ، نعم ، نحن نتزلج في دبي
نقول أن الوقت كان درسًا عن
التعثر في
البلطجة التي تفعل الكثير من القسوة ، لم أكن أقصد أن
هارونا ربما كان لديه ورقة واحدة من
أجل  يتمثل جزء كبير من مهمتنا
هنا في التأكد من أن طيور البطريق
دائمًا سعيدة وبصحة جيدة وهذا
يتضمن الكثير من الأشياء من
أسماك ذات نوعية جيدة مياه ذات نوعية جيدة ولكن
نظام الإضاءة يعمل بشكل صحيح ،
نسجل كل ما تفعله البطاريق
من خلال الكمية التي تأكلها  كم عدد الضيوف
الذين التقوا بهم اليوم وإذا كانوا يتعلمون
أي شيء جديد أو حتى لو كانوا يتكاثرون
جميعًا ، أنيا تومي هانسن
نموذج المقيِّد المعتاد الأفيال أبا إيبان
تخيل أنك تقصد حداد مو الذي تحدث إلى زان
الموضوعي يسمى سومطرة جافا
تيرميناتور محركات تصديق الفيلم با النموذج
تقي  الأصدقاء الذين يحضرون بشكل كبير للغاية
بعد قضية Luke الأثيري والحساسة للسيدة
الكندية ، دعوه لي جميعًا
سيدفن الكثير من الناس يسألون عن العمر الذي
ينظر إليه البطريق وأنا أفتح  البرية
للأسف تتراوح عادة بين 15
و 20 عامًا ومنشآت مثل منشآتنا
حيث تكون محمية ، يمكن أن تمتد من 30 إلى 40
عامًا ، الشيء موجود في البرية ، لم
يعد معتدلًا بعد الآن ، البرية خطيرة ، كما
تعلمون ، هناك أشياء مثل التلوث
والاحتباس الحراري يزيد من  تقلل الحيوانات المفترسة
من مخزون الأسماك التي
لا تؤثر على طيور البطريق فحسب ، بل تؤثر على
الحياة البحرية بأكملها عندما تعرف إيتاليا هولا الحزين ،
يمكنك بسرعة هيذر
، ومع ذلك ،
لا يمكنني القيام بذلك عن طريق شراء
تذكرة
ضيوفنا يقومون بالفعل بتمويل
الأبحاث في البرية والتي نأمل
في النهاية أن تساعد طيور البطريق على البقاء على قيد الحياة
في البرية والبقاء بأمان في العالم
والعيش حياة سعيدة طويلة في البرية
وعدم وضع مرافق مثل أخرى